it's a pleasure to welcome to the
program today Rachel bitte coffer who is
an election forecaster and analyst and a
senior fellow at the Niskanen Center
Rachel it's so great to have you on yeah
it's great to be here thanks for having
me so let's get right into it so I've
sort of intuitively suspected for some
time that at least as a strategy for
winning elections convincing people to
change their minds about who they're
going to vote for is less efficient than
just finding people that agree with you
and getting them to go out and vote and
you wrote a piece a little while ago
where you are as I understand it
essentially supporting the idea of a
turnout strategy rather that rather than
a debate and change people's mind
strategy being a key to winning
elections am I correctly interpreting
your perspective and talk a little bit
about how you formed this idea yeah I
mean you are and it's its precipice on
this idea of a changed electorate right
so this idea that in the age of
polarization it's exceedingly difficult
to get people to change their minds and
that we have a much better and more
sophisticated understanding of electoral
behavior and voter opinions and we did
back in the days it certainly doesn't
advocate for an either/or I'm not a or
black or white individual in any
capacity of my life or my research so
I'm not saying you ignore persuasion I
would argue it's probably most effective
amongst that small group of pure
independence even probably would argue
its efficacy against look if you're a
Democrat trying to get an independent
that means towards Republicans to vote
for you would be a stretch let alone a
self-identified Republican but so I'm
not saying you shouldn't do persuasion
at all but you know until recently
Democrats pretty much engaged in almost
entirely in devoting their resources
towards persuading you know spending
GOTV money and their ad strategy and
their messaging and framing over this
idea of convincing voters of the other
party or voters that don't agree with
them to vote for them
I am arguing that they neglected to
consider shaping the electorate in their
image the way that the Republicans have
how have the Republicans done it and
what sorts of strategies work or can you
use to do that yes so the way that
Republicans have done it primarily is
through effective you know
research-based messaging strategies so
when you look at how a Republican run
like a Republican run campaign talks to
voters like they kind of meet the voter
where they are and you can't say that
the immigrants are or is good at that
and it's not a flattering place where
the American voter is unfortunately
Americans are not particularly civically
minded or engaged even the part that is
engaged in elections tend to be you know
pretty poorly informed so you know
Democrats tend to have an idealized
version of voters they tend to think
that voters want a very wonky policy
based discussion you know and hit them
with these types of mailers that are you
know pointing out well the Republicans
want to do this with you know abortion
funding and we want to do that whereas
Republicans are talking to voters
emotions and the reason that they do
that number one is because people are
better motivated by emotions but number
two you know if you were talking to
somebody who doesn't have a great
understanding of policy it's probably
cuz they don't have much interest in it
right and so if you are hitting them
with these wonky you know heavily word
Ladin policy appeals they're gonna tune
out pretty quickly you want to hit them
in a way that resonates with them and
conveys that information pretty quick so
Republicans really do certain techniques
I'm happy to get into like specific
details about that are much more
effective at getting up through to that
less inclined less civically engaged
voter now my instinct is that this works
better with some issues than with others
in the sense that there are issues that
naturally lend themselves more to a more
sort of visceral I've got to do
something about that sort of reaction is
that also a part of it which is figuring
out what is a
loading issue in the first place yeah I
mean there that's true right I mean to
some degree you can't to some degree you
can't creates aliens but I'll push back
hit that a little bit too because I mean
think about Benghazi right yeah
how many Republicans did you run into in
2016 that would point to especially the
ones that were like a little bit less
Trump like boo boo Trump and they would
say well yeah but Benghazi right I mean
just the fact that they could name
Benghazi as a main mean issue is a
testament to how much you can actually
push and mold public opinion and voter
like salience if you are effective at it
and you know what you're doing because I
wonder I wonder was the Benghazi refrain
actually about Benghazi or was it the
emotion of being repelled by Hillary and
simply finding something to say about it
yeah I mean yes and no but like it's
such a niche issue but yet I still I
still run into people who say well I
voted for him but I had to because of
Benghazi like Democrats would tell you
that such a thing would be impossible to
do right so you know so it's so the
answer is you need to have the right
issue it needs to be an issue that
resonates with people but then you need
to talk about it in the right way so
like the Democrats will talk about
health care but they don't make it about
life and death
I mean sometimes they do and I think
they're getting better about conveying
you know if Medicaid expansion doesn't
pass this kid with pre-existing
conditions is going to die right that's
how Republicans would talk about
Medicaid expansion if we don't pass this
thing you're gonna dump okay and
Democrats don't want to take it to that
level of stakes right but that's how you
know Republicans everything is life or
death if you don't you know vote for a
Republican in 2019 in Virginia they're
gonna take your guns away it's not
they're gonna make modest reforms to the
gun laws that make it so that you have
additional hurdles to clear for a gun
purchase it's you know they're going to
take all your guns okay and so it's is a
two-fold problem that
let's have identifying the right issues
and you know frankly sometimes they're
decent at that but talking about them in
a way that for you and me work campaigns
are not about us campaigns are about
those people that don't give a poop
about politics about policy and the
reason is that nobody is is explained to
them how important that policy is to
them personally the stakes that those
things have for them and you know we I
would say are I would argue Democrats
tend to make campaigns that are already
designed to talk to voters that are care
about politics so using this model and
applying it to the 2020 election pre
coronavirus first and then we'll talk
about maybe what's going on now how
would you have assessed the likely
outcome of the election on this basis
before the virus well so you know I mean
if you're familiar with my research you
know I put my forecasts out for the
presidential election before the virus I
mean months and months before yes and
that posted an update based on the
conclusion of the Democratic primary
which you know for me as a trained
political scientist with an expertise in
presidential nominations knew was a
mathematical certainty after the Super
Tuesday contests and so I updated my
forecast based on the conclusion of the
Democratic primary and and you know an
inevitability that Joe Biden would be
the nominee and I talked a little bit
about how I could not yet account for
effects for the pandemic and the
economic collapse that's going to
accompany it but also said that I'm not
sure that it's gonna matter all that
much and in the forecast for Congress
that I released tomorrow so you know
shameless plug my congressional forecast
that's been long awaited and much
anticipated is going to be dropped
tomorrow yes hold on getting interrupted
by Kidd which is like you know
quintessential pandemic that's such a
key moment as well the you know the
Congress forecast is gonna talk okay now
we're a further a month further down the
road and and like I anticipated the
pandemic has not moved a public-opinion
about Donald Trump at all right Blake
we are a public that is completely
incapable of responding to massive
political stimulus because of
polarization and hyper partisanship you
know so so when you ask me you know is
it going to be before or after there's
not gonna be much difference to tell you
the truth right now and where do you see
it then yeah and and that forecast
you know anticipates a very good
election cycle for Democrats given that
Democrats and independents especially
you know left-leaning independence of
which there are a great deal of and
especially in this audience I would
guess because you know when we think
about who or independence there are
disproportionately younger voters and
they're disproportionately white great
you know demographically but anyway
left-leaning independence and also pure
independence of people who don't lean
who broke for Trump in 2016 but my
research predicts will probably vote in
favor of the Democrat in this cycle and
I think the one area that that the
forecast might change a little bit is I
think that that Trump's problem with
pure independence has probably been
compounded by the pandemic and the
economic collapse because he is not a
great leader as you know I'm objectively
you know if you were to say okay how is
Trump handling the crisis and you let
laid out a set of metrics that you would
want a leader to meet in terms of this
particular crisis and the things that
internationally luckily this is a crisis
that we can do that with because it's a
crisis that the world shares right so
you have a set of objective standards
that are put forward by health policy
professionals and the United States is
failing very poorly in preparing fairly
poorly at these standards objectively
and I think that is going to probably
impact that pure independent voting
block a little bit in the election now
in terms of trumps approval not being
affected it does look like according to
the Gallup tracking poll we saw the
largest decline in approval between
takes so to speak a nine-point decline
which we've not seen during the
presidency it's still within the same
range right it's still not a new number
that we haven't seen before but the the
precipitous decline seems novel but you
don't really think that it's moving
dramatically in a substantive way yeah
so another advantage I think that I can
bring to forecasting and election
analysis is that I am I believe the only
forecaster anyway in like race
handicapper that also doubled as a as an
active and you know a really experienced
pollster so I spent five years running
polls many many many polls so I'm a very
well-versed in polling methodology and
so opinions me to say that something has
been going weird in the Gallup poll from
the last couple of years really and I
haven't been including it I'm I do a
very different model than you know the
traditional method used by silver and
and many of the other analysts is to
throw every poll into a model because
you know oh it will the noise will get
canceled out if you just aggregate them
all whereas I am actually a very snobby
poll digester I do want more than one
poll I'm not big on one poll but I also
will not include polls that seemed that
have certain methodologies that have you
know low-end sizes like it mean
basically if the poll has a little in
size I don't even look at the results of
it
you know I at some point will put out
like a guide to pull watching for people
to follow because actually it's
astounding to me like how many really
take really big name people use polling
data in a way that is actually
statistically inappropriate so you know
polling is interesting but yeah so we
look at Trump's polling data using you
know decent data what we will see is
that there was a two or three point
rally around the flag effect yes and the
untrained eye during that week of this
was like oh look Trump has a rally
around the flag effect he's getting more
popular but a trained I looked at it
mine
said Oh God look at this like this is
the most amazing muted rally around the
flag effect we've ever seen in
presidential politics it's completely
atypical we should see a 10 15 20 I mean
really like for this crisis this type of
crisis something that's completely
externally caused it's you know what we
would call without blame I mean at least
in the beginning when the pump before
the public begins to realize you know
the decision-making in the early process
external crisis started outside of the
country's borders something that we
would have expected prior to
polarization a 20-point rally around the
flat effect for and the fact that he'd
bear I mean basically did not get one is
a real testament both to how unpopular
he is personally but also to how
powerful polarization hyper-partisanship
are in American politics right now and
you know I'll be talking quite a bit
about this in this congressional
forecast that comes out tomorrow so on
the radio TV show and podcast were going
to go to a break but we'll have our full
conversation with Rachel on the YouTube
channel so looking back at presidential
approval with George W Bush for example
at 9/11 his approval went to close to 90
at the start of the Iraq war it went to
71 and that was not a situation we had
no control over it was a decision and a
choice to go to war so those would be
the data point you would compare to and
say the three or four points Trump God
is just very small in comparison for a
rally around the president yeah I mean
personally I consider in a non effect a
not affect okay fair enough so let me
ask you this there there are a lot of
people who email me and who have you
been emailing me throughout the primary
saying only X candidate if they were to
be the nominee could defeat Donald Trump
in November and typically the sort of
names that are included there were
either Bernie Sanders Andrew yang or
Tulsi Gabbard those were the three whose
followers seemed more likely to email me
and say this is the only person that can
be trumped would your analysis be
fundamentally different if for example
Bernie Sanders were
the nominee instead of Joe Biden in this
particular case yes so here's where the
Sanders nomination was would be
different is that Democrats are not
Republican so when Donald Trump executed
a hostile ideological takeover and his
tight takeover I mean it's kind of weird
right it's got elements of a far-right
takeover but it's also nationalist and
it's also populist and it forced the
party into positions they had never
before considered and you know it all so
it's you know forced them into some very
you know problematic positions on race
and and things like that but you know
what Sanders had he won the nomination
it would have been via could probably a
brokered conventions because of the as
it played out anyway he didn't he wasn't
winning big
you know delegate count contests right
and so what would have happened in my
estimation is Democratic um you know
other candidates running in the Senate
running in the house would have freaked
out because they don't have the I'm so
sorry Gabey is uh gonna have to get
kicked out of here real quick Dave
sounds like looks like it's snowing in
there all we all have to roll in the
agent yes indeed yes anyway you know
with with my estimation is I think what
would happen is the Republicans - they
would have been very shrewd and pushing
this the party's establishment is
convinced and I know the Sanders crowd
is convinced it's about corporatism and
corruption but I it actually comes from
a genuine belief that a Sanders type
candidate would not win election and
that's because you know these you know
candidates and the the party's
mainstream consulting class an election
class is wholeheartedly convinced that
their path to electoral winning must run
through conversion of Republican voters
for some reason
now Republicans don't have to somehow
win election ever by converting
Democrats and there's more Democrats but
somehow Democrats must win office by
converting Republicans and because of
that then if you have a nominee who's a
self-described socialist then you have
sentenced yourself to electoral loss
right so that's the claim from some in
other words yes no it's not a claim it's
a deep-seated belief yeah they all
believe it so it's not about corporatism
for defending the corporate structures
and the elites I mean you know what it
is is about okay they think that Bernie
Sanders is unelectable and that by
putting them on the ticket they would be
sentencing you know the party to four
more years of Trump and costing all
these other candidates their races and
they believe that Sanders people
listening to this just as deeply as you
believe the things that you believe okay
okay so you know if you can put yourself
into another person's shoes that's a
really important because that will help
you understand my next point my next
point is because they have that
deep-seated belief what they would do
and they're not Republicans so they're
not they're not the kind of people that
will say okay you know this is the guy
though that we've been handed and the
only way that we can have any shot of
winning is to stay in line basically
right the Republican Party did you know
in some ways fracture at times around
Trump you had the Access Hollywood video
came out and Republicans like I'm not
gonna you know he should step out and we
had some moments where the party freaked
out but by and large elites did coalesce
around him now they didn't they didn't
you know go to the convention and
endorse him and give speeches on his
behalf
but they didn't fight him right they did
not run against their own party so like
the Democratic campaign would have
played out in 2018 where like Mark Kelly
in Arizona for example would have been
running two campaigns at once he would
have been running a campaign against
Trump which is a referendum campaign
that's very effective and is the one
that my
predicts Democrats will win okay problem
is he would also be running a
campaigning and socialism and
Republicans would artfully because
there's so much federate strategy be
forcing and tricking and into devoting
as much time and resource into that
campaign as possible because that's a
campaign Republicans think that they can
win a and B that's a campaign that
diverts resources and attention away
from the candy and Republicans know they
will lose which is a referendum on Trump
okay so let me make sure I understand
that so if Bernie were the nominee and
you had today Mark Kelly running against
Martha McSally in Arizona Mark Kelly
would be running against Martha McSally
as a referendum on Trump with because
mcsalley is more of associated with
Trump but simultaneously Kelly would
have to be distancing from the Bernie
Sanders model yes right not as this
Democratic CEO that I remember when I
said that people make the mistake of
assuming everyone's like them yes and
here if you're listening to this you
know show in any capacity I have really
great news for you you're in the 1% not
the economic 1% okay you're in the
politically engaged like into
intellectual 1% and that means that you
are a particularly terrible frame of
reference by which to judge anything
about other people because you are the
creme de la creme you are the smartest
most engaged most passionate and most
interested like American voter out there
you could probably tell me 10 maybe 20
of the Democratic candidates that ran in
this primary where the Mogul American
voter and not even the ones that set out
the elections but the one that will
actually vote in November couldn't only
tell me maybe Biden Warren Chlo Bashar
Budaj and Sanders that would be the
extent of the repertoire of like your
average you know blue or white collar so
non-college educated or college educated
average American
okay like that so we are not good people
to think about how how average like the
average bell curve of the electorate
does things and so so that's where
birdie like the this is where I have
argued progressives actually had a
moment here in this cycle that was that
they had a really a good moment for the
message but they had a really
problematic messenger because the party
is so is so spooked about people who
have the specific label of socialist and
Bernie has so much video that you know
that it was very easy to spook these
mainstream candidates into thinking that
they would get dragged down by his
candidacy so so if you're asking me like
my forecast tomorrow that people are
gonna really want to look at yes it
would look different if Bernie Sanders
was going to be the nominee because a he
would be getting that nomination
sometime now in August by a brokered
convention assuming this pandemic still
happens in other words he'd be earning
it having earned a plurality of the
delegates winning the most out of
everybody but not a majority enough to
secure the nomination and that does not
indicate consensus right in the party
and number two because I would assume
that the party wouldn't spend as much
time running against itself as running
against Trump because of the socialist
problem now it's possible that Democrats
especially you know having my research
publicly available where I make this
point clear and I've been making this
point clear for about two years that the
danger isn't so much the candidate as it
is but party's belief that the candidate
is unelectable but you know my
assumption is yes that you know that
division of message would probably cost
them you know something you know some
electoral ground yeah Rachel it's an
absolute pleasure to talk to you and we
will be very
excitedly awaiting that assessment
tomorrow we've been speaking with Rachel
bitte Kapur who's an election forecaster
analyst and senior fellow at the
niskanen Center Rachel really appreciate
your time today thanks so much for
having me and please follow me on
Twitter and do a lot of everyday
commentary there so